and so the idea is something like this
it's very counter-intuitive
um so the way to describe it is to say
that your brain doesn't react to things
in the world
it's not it to us it feels like our eyes
and our
um our windows on the world we see
things we hear things
we we react to them um in psychology we
call this stimulus response
so um your face is your voice is a
stimulus to me
i receive input and then i react to it
and i might react very automatically you
know
system one and uh oh but i also might
execute some control where i maybe
stop myself from saying something or
doing something
and um more in a more reflective way
execute a different action right that's
system two
the way the brain works though is it's
predicting all the time
it's constantly talking to itself
constantly
uh talking to your body and it's
predicting what's going on in the body
and what's going on in the world
and making predictions and um
the information from your body and from
the world really
confirm or correct those predictions so
fundamentally the thing
that the brain does most of the time is
just predict like talking to yourself
and predicting stuff about the world
not like this dumb thing that just
senses in response senses
yeah so the way the way to think about
it is like this you know your brain
is uh trapped in a dark silent box
yeah that's very romantic of you um
which is your skull and the only
information that it receives
from your body and from the world right
is through the senses
through the sense organs your eyes your
ears
and um you have a sense sensory data
that comes from your body
uh that you're largely unaware of to
your brain which we call interroceptive
as opposed to exterceptive which is the
world around you
and but your brain is receiving
sense data continuously
which are the effect of some set of
causes
your brain doesn't know the cause of
these
sense data it's only receiving the
effects of those causes which are the
data
themselves and so your brain has to
solve what philosophers call an inverse
inference problem
how do you know when you only receive
the effects of something how do you know
what caused those effects so
when there's a flash of light or a
change in air pressure or
a tug somewhere in your body how does
your brain
know what caused those
events so that it knows what to do next
to keep you alive and well
and the answer is that your brain has
one other source of information
available
to it which is your past experience
it can reconstitute in its wiring
past experiences and it can combine
those past experiences
in novel ways and so
we have lots of names for this in
psychology we call it
memory we call it perceptual inference
we call it simulation
it's also we call it concepts or
conceptual knowledge
we call it prediction basically if we
were to
stop the world right now stop time
your brain is in a state
and it's representing
what it believes is going on in your
body and in the world
and it's predicting what will happen
next
based on past experience right
probabilistically what's most likely to
happen
and it begins to
prepare your action
and it begins to prepare your
the prepare your experience
based so it's anticipating the sense
data it's going to receive
and then when that those data come in
they
either confirm that prediction and your
action executes
because the plan's already been made or
um it uh were there some
sense data that your brain didn't
predict that's unexpected
and your brain takes it in we say
encodes it
we have a fancy name for that we call it
learning
your brain learns and it updates its
storehouse of knowledge which we call an
internal model
and uh that you so that you can predict
better next time and it turns out that
predicting and correcting predicting and
correcting
is a much more metabolically efficient
way to run a system
than constantly reacting all the time
because if you're constantly reacting it
means you have no
you can't anticipate in any way what's
going to happen and so the
the amount of uncertainty that you have
to deal with is
uh overwhelming to a nervous system
metabolically costly i like it
and so what is a reflex a reflex is when
your brain doesn't check against
the sense data that the potential cost
to you is so great maybe because
you know your life is threatened that
your brain
makes the prediction and executes the
action
without checking yeah so but prediction
is still at the core that's a beautiful
vision of the brain
you